opening night last night I I don't I
quit going to media day a long time ago
it's just too much it's too many young
people it's too hectic it's too crazy
but Peter your reaction to to what you
witnessed there last night I mean I
thought I thought the league did a nice
job before the cheat the Chiefs went
first
they went from 7:00 to 8:00 and then the
Niners went from 9:00 to 10:00 but I
thought the NFL did a nice job with the
Kobe Bryant tribute right before yeah
Chiefs that was that was appropriate I
thought because so many guys on these
two teams loved Kobe Bryant you know the
prior generation they might have loved
Michael Jordan sure this generation
loved Kobe Bryant and I think so many of
these guys were really devastated but
Kyle Shanahan last night talking about
how he was devastated by it you know
hearing about it on the 49ers play nice
so I thought that part of it was good
and then you know somebody said to me so
can you tell anything from this opening
night I mean how did the Niners act how
did the Chiefs act I said come on I mean
it's a it's a it's a time where we're
guys just have to sit somewhere for an
hour and talk about themselves how
possibly can you get any inkling of
what's gonna happen in a football game
by listening to George Kittel talk about
himself which he does all the time
anyway right you know so I there's
nothing you can tell it was um so I
didn't have it in my hotel I had to get
it on my phone right I didn't have the
channel so I'm streaming it on my phone
and yeah yeah like I'm getting heckled
down but it was I just look at it like
this yeah I don't tell anything I don't
think there's any great moments to me
it's just the spectacled and the NFL
does do a great job of putting on the
show and I think for for me the players
everybody involved to me it's just the
kickoff of the Super Bowl week and
especially for the players that's where
I get move most of a kick out of it it's
just watching them come out and to
realize like whoa you're in the
Superbowl we're the only game on in
America on Sunday this week and all of
football college NFL and it doesn't
matter and you see the guys filming
themselves and just the event itself
because it's a special time to me that's
the thing that I think that always kind
of rings true to me it really is a
spectacle though the winter
was the guy who was in the Andy Reid
punt pass he was around here yesterday
misspell from the Monday Night Football
game all those years ago but there was
some football talk there was some
discussion about what is going to happen
on Sunday and among others Richard
Sherman the 49ers cornerback was asked
about the challenge that they'll be
facing with the Chiefs offense and
Sherman was told hey look
mahomes isn't going to shy away from
your side of the field are you ready
here's what Sherman had to say they got
some of the most dynamic playmakers in
his league they got a ton of speed he
got a ton of arm talent he can get the
ball wherever he wants it when he wants
it he can move around the pocket you
know we got it we got to find a way to
to get that soul you know they have a
great offense in and obviously a ton of
playmakers that's why that's what I hear
that's what he made to the show yeah
look they're gonna have a rough time
they're gonna have a rough time I mean
Tyreke Hill is gonna run circles around
guys like Richard Sherman if Patrick
Holmes has enough time told to wait for
those guys to get open they're
eventually gonna get open it yeah it's
beat the clock as to whether or not
mahomes will have enough time when he's
being chased by the front for the 49ers
to find a guy who's eventually gonna be
no question I mean to me that's the key
of the game right now right I mean
that's all we can really talk about we
don't know how that's gonna unfold
Kansas City protects well my home's a
magician in the pocket whoa he hasn't
played a defensive line like this all
year I saw a few other you know moments
with Richard Sherman he went back to
your point Mike a few times which told
me like he knows he can't cover these
guys all day long he kind of referenced
like hey we got to make sure we do a
good job of corralling him in the
backfield he made a lot of comments like
that too I think he's saying like I I
can't cover this guy for seven seconds
that's just not gonna happen I think
he's very realistic about that so that
is gonna be one of the big things I mean
what's the number I asked you guys to
where you would go okay
mahomes and the Chiefs are in trouble as
far as sacks are concerned right like if
San Francisco gets four sacks are you
going Oh Kansas cities in trouble if
it's a visit less now do you guys I
think what it is it's how long is it
going to be from homes to have in the
pocket before he gets in you know severe
pressure right because look this is
something that the most interesting
single statistic going into this game in
my opinion is that since the start of
the 18 season when mahomes started
starting he has one twenty point three
quarterback rating when he throws in 2.5
seconds or less yeah and that is sort of
the line of demarcation that's kind of
the magic number if you get to a
quarterback in 2.5 seconds or less
you're really bothering him and I think
the reason why he's so good at it is
that he's fine
when he has to leave the pocket yeah he
makes so many plays off platform that
that that is why I think it's hard to
say I think he could get a couple of
cheapy sacks early
yeah just you're trying to buy and make
a play yeah some more time yeah exactly
but I do think that the biggest thing in
this game is pressure before you get to
that line of demarcation pressure at 2.1
2.2 so he doesn't have time to find
Tyree kill much pass Richard Sherman and
I think that's the key early on you take
a sack or two to understand how much
time you're gonna have to adjust
yeah just okay they're gonna get to me
in three seconds I got to get rid of the
foot Mike safe with us saying that I
think this is so Dean P's last week I
was talking to him about this game and
and I pointed out I said does that
surprise you that Andy Reid who was so
ready with the rpoS for this game did
rpoS on the first two snaps of this game
the AFC Championship game and then the
rest of the 64 snaps of the game never
ran an RPO yes and Dean Pease basically
told me you know 47-year it coach he
said listen Andy Reed is one of those
guys he can adjust a minute into a game
right and then he knows what isn't going
to worry and we're gonna do something
totally different I think he'll do the
exact same thing here and that's why
we're target if he takes a couple of
cheapy sex early that is an education
too and Erie sure it's gonna tell him we
got to do something different now right
we'll cross out this part of my play
sheet let's move on I got other ways to
attack a hundred percent here's another
interesting thing just cuz you brought
up Dean P's and this is something my dad
told me this week cuz he was in Kansas
City last week for Titans you know
Titans Chiefs game and you know he told
me this because it was a WOW factor
comment he had never heard a team say
this about an opposing team quarterback
and I don't think I've ever heard a team
say it either
he Dean P's told my father he goes we're
not gonna blitz Patrick mahomes and they
were kind of like well why and he goes
because we can't rattle him there's he's
not it's it's not possible you can't
rattle Patrick mahomes he says we've
we've seen him for two years in the NFL
there's not one moment anybody could
find in our department that this guy
gets shaken or a little confused by the
moment or whatever it may be so I mean
to what we're saying here first off this
isn't a phenomenal talent in the homes
like that he hasn't seen a deadline like
this I do want to state that one more
time this is gonna be a different animal
but I I'm just interested to see how
that plays out
yeah it's a cheapie saksad they're not
as effective you're right that's that's
a great way to put it
like a two-yard seconds what I'm saying
yeah right and also like you're saying
he's buying time cuz he's right sure he
just wants to be safe with the ball
that's different than oh man like the
Red Sea is parted and Bosa and Ford are
coming around and hitting him at two
seconds every time if we get a lot of
those sacks then I go whoa Kansas City's
in deep trouble how much do we think D
Ford who was with the Chiefs last year
and the year before when Pat mahomes was
just a practice guy who was Wow everyone
privately right and the rest of us
didn't know how good he was but D Ford
was there to see it
how much does D Ford know understand
about how he moves about how he runs is
that helpful or ultimately does it not
matter because yeah he's great he's
great I've seen it there's nothing you
can do about it you go try to catch him
and maybe you get lucky but more often
than not you're not gonna get I don't
see how it helps but Chris has played he
would know well yeah I don't think it's
a huge deal I do think like I bet
there's a number of times where my homes
went against D Ford in practice D Ford
got around the edge and thought oh man
this is like I'm you know of course he
can't sack them in practice but they
touch him down or do something like that
I bet you mahomes gives a move I mean he
might have a feel for his first escape
move ooh when he leans forward he's
about to dip out the back door and and
spin out that way I don't know that
might help him out there's no problem
you have to learn body language they
will study body language during the week
to go yes they're gonna try to find a
predictability to go oh if he leans this
way he's really gonna make a move the
other way whatever it is but it's gonna
be very hard to do that in real time
another topic that came up last night
and look it's the topic we discussed
last week it's a topic that the Titans
didn't take to heart the way they should
have when he becomes a runner you have
to go tackle him and DeForest Buckner
said I'm getting him down I'm getting
him down you've got to be smart about it
obviously if it's on the sidelines
you're gonna try to tackle him if he
jumps out of bounds you got to try to
get out of the way I don't know how else
to explain it there's so many rules
nowadays protecting the quarterback I'm
not sure I'm a football player so I'm
gonna hit him as legal as possible and
you know this was the issue that we got
into last week the gray area right you
can't just shut down in the gray area
not with the Super Bowl on the lawn I
mean you can't you can't freak out like
the Titans did and watch him run right
by you and between DeForest Buckner and
Fred Warner and Dre Green law last night
the message was they have to go try to
make the play yeah you can't reside in
your fear that that as you lock in and
move toward the guy if he steps over the
line or if he goes into his slide and
there's nothing you can just start how
many times do we say when a guy gets a
flag for hitting someone late or hitting
someone into a slot what else could he
have done right you've committed yes
nothing you can do right no no there is
nothing you can do and that's why you
know - Mike - everything you said I
think you were spot-on it's not about
hurting the player it's just making him
feel the presence of the defense oh you
want to Oh face it the franchise to
Kansas City face of the NFL you want to
run around well we're gonna make you pay
I mean I like I said yesterday I'd be
disappointed if Robert Solow wasn't
preaching that to his defense and I
would expect him really to say you know
Aaron hitting him early like if you
think it's close hit him
and well if we get the penalty okay well
so be it but we know the line of
demarcation of what we can and can't get
away with and we'll adjust as the game
goes on but that that's the the message
I would give it to my team and everybody
out there I'm not asking for Patrick
mom's to get hurt are you kidding me I
don't want to see him get hurt I want to
watch him play so but I'm just saying if
you're a defender you got to have that
type of attitude if you don't if you
don't you're gonna be the guy on the
highlight as he runs into the end zone
for a touchdown or you're gonna like
tramaine Brock Imani hooker sure those
guys who look like Keystone Cops last
week when they they were they were
paralyzed by the fact that this
quarterback had become a runner and they
didn't know what to do
look the bill vinovich officiating crew
has a different kind of task on its
hands this week and that is particularly
you know the not not necessarily the
back judge but I'm talking about the
guys who were near the line of scrimmage
and their job is to know okay when
Patrick mahomes becomes a runner he
gives up his protections that he has as
a quarterback so when he becomes a
runner he's got to know that the 49ers
are gonna treat him as a runner yeah
just like they would treat him as a
running back in the open field and that
is something that I think you know the
announcing crew they that everybody
should know going into this game that
that Patrick mahomes might get hit very
hard in the open field and he doesn't
have the same protections he has in the
pocket this is the most physical
explosive fast defense he's played all
year and the 49ers and we've talked
about it all year this this defense is
it's made to stop a guy like Patrick
mahomes now whether it can do it I don't
know we're gonna see that's a whole
different story this guy's special we
haven't seen many people like him in the
history of the NFL but I know I'm
astounded when I watch 49ers film I sit
there and just go whoa the team speed on
defense is off the charts and they got
big guys as you know they are one of
those all-time get off the bus look in
teams like where you just go whoo this
is a special group here and that's where
you know I I just find the whole matchup
very intriguing
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports